they called it their dawn
surprise a golden plaque declaring
thailand belongs to the people the
latest challenge to the monarchy by
pro-democracy
protesters made in the shadow of the
country's grand palace
long live the people they shouted
[Music]
as demonstrators queued to get a
miniature metal version of the symbol
which sold out in minutes
[Applause]
before a convoy snaked its way towards
the grand palace
with a plan to present a list of demands
including reform of the monarchy to the
king's advisers
a bold act in a country where defaming
the royals
can land you in prison i think it's very
big move for thai people
to do the monarchy because we're like
they were like very
hard to touch before and but now we are
we like feel like we're able to touch
them
and then like i think it's very big move
for us
before they could reach their
destination lines of police
blocked the way both sides had vowed to
avoid violence
and there were no clashes as this
student leader gave their petition to
the police chief
a moment celebrated as a victory by the
demonstrators
[Applause]
how significant is today for the protest
movement
we now prove that even an ordinary
citizen
can communicate and communicate
with the king with the monarch with our
monarch directly
if the letters are unresponsive we will
escalate our movement
the government said it's willing to
listen but previously warned to steer
clear of the topic of the monarchy
today marked a milestone in these
protesters fight
but it isn't over more demonstrations
are planned for later
this week siobhan robbins sky news
bangkok